IN JUST A MOMENT BUT WE'RE GONNA
BE AGAIN AND KIND OF ALMOST IN
REVERSE ORDER -- WE'RE GONNA
START WITH -- ISSUE THREE AND
GET THE INFORMATION ITEM OUT OF
THE WAY SINCE WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR A QUORUM AND AND
THEY'RE READY TO GO AND THEN
WE'LL -- MOVE ON TO THE TSC.
IF YOU WANT TO SET UP THE WE'LL
START IN JUST A MINUTE
.
WE ARE STILL WAITING ON A QUORUM
BUT I'LL A CALL THE MEETING TO
ORDER -- WILL -- HAVE A QUORUM
SHORTLY I'M SURE BUT WE WILL NOW
BEGIN -- WITH -- WITH -- ISSUE.
THREE UNDER THE US SECRETARY FOR
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND
TO WE HAVE A TOLL ROAD
LEGISLATION INFORMATION ITEM AND
I BELIEVE LA -- IS GOING TO
PRESENT TO ON THAT ITEM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M YOUR STAFF
HAS ASKED THAT WE PRESENT THIS
INFORMATION ITEM FREE TODAY --
AT THAT THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT
THERE ARE PUBLIC TOLL FACILITIES
WITHIN THE STATE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ENGAGED ENGAGED IN
ACTIVE LITIGATION.
REGARDING THE USE AND SHARING AS
I'M CERTAIN INFORMATION
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION AND TOLL AGENCIES
WILL SHARE THIS INFORMATION AND
THAT WITH THE DMV OR FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD. FOR PURPOSES AS AND
FINE DEAN HOW TO CONTACT -- TOLL
VIOLATORS OR FOR THE PURPOSES OF
COLLECTIONS -- THE THERE'S
VARIOUS LOCAL A TOOL A THIRTIES
THAT ARE PROPOSING THIS I'M
LEGISLATION.
AND THAT IS BEING DISCUSSED
TODAY BY THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATION ATTEMPTS TO CLARIFY
THE WAY THAT THIS PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION -- IS
ADDRESSED IN THE STATUTE FOR
TOLL AUTHORITIES I YOUR STAFF IS
NOTING HERE AT THAT TIME BEING
ABLE TO SHARE THIS PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION IS
OBVIOUSLY.
I REASONABLE AND A NECESSARY
PART FOR THE OF THE TOLL
THIRTIES TO CONDUCT THEIR
BUSINESS AND COLLECT TOLLS ON
THE PARTICULAR ON TOLL VIOLATORS --
HOWEVER GIVEN SOME OF THE
SENSITIVITY IMPORTANCE REGARDING
SHARING OF PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION YOUR
STAFF NOTES AT THIS OP PROPOSAL
AND THAT LEGISLATION THAT THIS
GROUP IS SEEKING.
MIGHT BE A BETTER FIT TO BE
PURSUED TO THE POLICY PROCESS
AND SO THOSE AND AT THE THE
SENSITIVITY AROUND PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION CAN BE
CONSIDERED AN AND WEIGHED
AGAINST HOW THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION SHARED WITH OTHER
AGENCIES AS WELL.
HI THANK YOU -- ARMS OR ANY
OTHER -- THIS MONEY LIKE THAT --
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS BOB
FRIENDS WHERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY -- CAL TO DOES NOT HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON OPPOSE
LANGUAGE BUT UNDERSTANDS THE
CONCERN OF THE PUBLIC TOLL
COLLECTION AGENCIES WITH REGARD
TO LITIGATION AND THE REST OF
TOTAL REVENUE -- SHOULD TOLL
VIOLATIONS AND NON PAYMENTS
INCREASE TRANSPORTATION PREVENTS
ARE PUT AT RISK.
HOWEVER PRIVACY PROTECTIONS IS
ALSO KEY IN THE TOLLS MUST BE
CORRECT IN THE MANNER THAT CAN
PROTECT CONSUMER PRIVACY.
THANK YOU -- DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
JAMES MORE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OF THE GROUP ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY -- AGENCY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WANT WE PAUSE AND TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM.
BLOOM HERE FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON RAY YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM SEEING
NONE -- IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
MS RESTED ON THIS BUT WE'RE ON
THE INFORMATION ITEM NUMBER.
THREE VOTE ONLY NUMBER THREE I'M
EXCUSE ME ITEM TO BE HER NUMBER.
THREE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS FOR YOU BEGIN.
THIS RACE MIGHT HAVE A QUESTION
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY.
HI THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE A TOP.
OF THE HALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WE ARE
ONE OF THE THE TOLL COLLECTING
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT -- DOES SUPPORT THIS ITEM --
AND HAVE REQUESTED IT -- THE
STATE HAS GIVEN US DIRECTION
OVER THE YEARS -- TO PURSUE --
TOLLING AS A MEANS OF CONGESTION
MANAGEMENT OVER THE YEARS IT'S
ALSO.
ALSO OPPOSES MANDATES ABOUT
INTER OPERABILITY AND HOW WE
DEAL WITH APPEALS MECHANISMS IN
A WHOLE BODY OF LAW RELATED TO
TOLL COLLECTION -- BUT WE ARE
AND WE ALSO HAVE -- A BODY OF
LAW RELATED TO PRIVACY
PROVISIONS AND WE TAKE BOTH OF
THOSE CHARGES VERY SERIOUSLY THE
CHALLENGES THAT THOSE -- THOSE
MULTIPLE STATUTES THERE ARE SOME
PERCEIVED INCONSISTENCIES
BETWEEN THOSE STATUTES AND SO IT
MAKES.
OUR THE WORKABILITY OF OUR TOLL
FACILITIES -- CHALLENGED AND SO
WE DO COME BEFORE YOU ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THE ITEM -- WE
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT ITEM
FROM A BUDGET PERSPECTIVE
BECAUSE THE THE BUDGET
RAMIFICATIONS FOR AGENCIES ARE
SIGNIFICANT AND WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS TO SEE IF
WE CAN FINE TUNE THIS LANGUAGE
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH YOUR
STAFF.
I WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO DO
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU -- THIS
IS ME MISTER CHAIRMAN RICHARD
HARRIS FROM THE NORSEMAN FIRM ON
BEHALF OF THE TOLL ROAD.
TOLL ROADS OF ORANGE COUNTY THAT
TRANSPORTATION QUARTER AGENCIES
OF ORANGE COUNTY -- JUST TO ADD
A COUPLE OF THINGS I WAS ONE OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WAS HERE IN
TWENTY TEN WHEN SENATORS TO MANY
AND STARTED HIS -- LEGISLATION
WHICH LED US TO THE THREE ONE
FOUR NINE NOW.
AND HE WAS VERY CLEAR SENATORS
TO MILLIONS VERY CLEAR IN HIS
INTENT AND THAT THE TOLL
AGENCIES WOULD BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE -- INSISTED
THAT HE WOULD NEED TO PROTECT AS
WE WANT TO DO THIS -- PRIVATE TO
INFORMATION AND HIS INTENT WAS
SENT -- TO THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE
GOT THE HIS FACT SHEET WE'VE GOT
IS BACKGROUND INFORMATION AND
WAS VERY CLEAR THAT.
IT WAS NOT TO INTERFERE WITH --
INTER OPERABILITY AMONG AGENCIES
AS WELL AS JUST THE BASIC
COLLECTION -- OF TOLLS -- IN
THAT INFORMATION THAT SHARED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES -- AND IN SOME
INSTANCES THE CHP -- WE ARE A
COMPLETE PARTNER THEY AGENCIES
ARE WITH THE WITH THE STATE AND
THE RAMIFICATIONS -- COULD BE --
COULD BE LARGE -- TO THE STATE
REMEMBER THAT FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
ORANGE COUNTY TOLL ROADS ARE ALL
STATE HIGHWAYS.
THEY WERE BUILT WITH NON
RECOURSE TOLL REVENUE BONDS AND
THAT'S HOW -- THEY WERE BUILT
BUT THAT BILLION NOW WORTH FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS TURNED OVER
TO THE STATE SO WE BUILD THAT.
AS STATE HIGHWAY STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SO WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE. TO LONG
LOTS GOING ON IN THE PRIVACY
SPACE SINCE TWENTY TEN AND
TWENTY NINETEEN ON A MAKE SURE
THAT ALL REALLY DOES FIT AND
WORKS RIGHT AND ALL THE MUTUAL
GOALS ARE ACCOMPLISHED SO WE'RE
VERY SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL -- I'M SORRY YES
ADDITIONAL CHAIR.
MIKE MONNA GONNA BE HALF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION -- THE RISK OF GOING
LAST IS THAT ALL THE REALLY GOOD
ARGUMENTS HAVE BEEN.
USED BEFORE BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
INTEROPERABLE INTER OPERABILITY
IS CRITICAL FOR THE TOLL
AGENCIES AS WELL AS A DMV.
TO A SUCCESSFULLY DO OUR
MANDATES AND WE APPRECIATE THE
PRIVACY ISSUES BUT I DON'T THINK
THIS IS ONE OF THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ENTRANCE WE WHICH ARE YOUR
AUNT'S WE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY.
WE SUPPORT -- THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE -- WE HAVE
BEEN OPERATING -- THE OUR
EXPRESS LANES IN LA COUNTY AS
LONG AS SOME OF THE OTHER
AGENCIES.
BUT WE FACE THE SAME MANDATES
WITH RESPECT TO HANDLING.
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION AND I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
IT'S NOT JUST TOLL -- DATA
GENERATED BY -- TOLD
TRANSACTIONS BUT IT'S ALSO
TRANSIT FARE CARDS AS WELL -- WE
HAVE A VERY ROBUST TAP PROGRAM
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WHICH ARE
AT A TIME WHEN WE ARE SEEING THE
CLING RIDERSHIP WE WANT TO MAKE
IT AS EASY.
AS POSSIBLE FOR THE TRANSIT
PATRONS -- TO PAY THEIR FAIRS
AND WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE THESE
PROGRAMS FOR AS FOR THOSE
REASONS WE LIKE.
TO AFTER THIS INFORMATION I
DON'T SEE THE SUBCOMMITTEE OR
SEE LEGISLATURE TAKE UP THE
MATTER AND ADDRESS IT.
SO WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IF THERE ARE NO --
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
IT IS OUR ONE MORE MISTER CHAIR
JONATHAN BEING IN THIS DIFFERENT
ROOM ASIDE HOLLERING ME OFF MY
GAME.
AROUND DOOR -- IT JUST ON BEHALF
OF ENTERPRISE HOLDINGS WANTED TO
JUST EXPRESS OUR INTEREST IN
THIS ISSUE AS WELL AS AN ENTITY
THAT WILL BE SUBJECT TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY.
PROTECTION ACT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WORKING WITH THE AGENCIES
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AS WELL
THANK.
THANK YOU -- IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THIS IS AN INFORMATION ITEM ONLY
THERE'S NO ACTION TO BE TAKEN
AND TO SO WE WILL UP MOVE BACK
TO THE BEGINNING OF OUR CALENDAR.
AND THE VOTE ON OUR VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR -- THERE ARE A SERIES
OF VOTES THAT -- WE SHOULD BE
TAKING THIS EVENING -- AT ALL
ENTERTAIN -- IN ALL OF THEM IT'S
A MOTION TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION SINCE EACH STAFF
RECOMMENDATION MIGHT BE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT FROM -- FROM THE OTHER
SO -- IF THERE IS A MOTION TO
APPROVE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
ISSUES 1-243-293-2330
436-239-40240 FOUR AND FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU.
BLOOM HI FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
RAY YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
THANK YOU NOW A IS THERE A
MOTION. TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON VOTE ONLY
ISSUES THIRTY ONE FORTY FORTY
ONE AND FORTY EIGHT BLOOM HI
FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAY YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
THANK YOU IS THERE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
ON VOTE ONLY IS IT PUT ONLY
ISSUES THREE THIRTY THIRTY FIVE
AND FORTY THREE BLOOM.
I FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
RAY YES.
RIVAS.
AND FINALLY IS THERE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
ON VOTE ONLY ISSUES FORTY SIX
AND FORTY SEVEN BLOOM.
HI FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN -- SEND.
RAY YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
WILL MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE ONE
UNDER DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ISSUE ONE IS
BASED FUNDING TO MAINTAIN
OPERATIONS [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
WOW [inaudible]
CAREFUL.
GOOD EVENING ANYTIME YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM.
MY NAME IS MEREDITH WILLIAMS I
AM THE ACTING DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ITS SUPPORT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
THE FUNDING SUPPORT AND
OVERSIGHT BY THE INDEPENDENT
REVIEW PANEL.
HAS ENABLED US TO IDENTIFY SOME
OF OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGES AND TO
MAKE INROADS INTO ADDRESSING
THEM.
WITH THE LOAN TO SUPPORT THE X.
I. CLEAN UP WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
CLEAN UP MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED
HOMES AND PROPERTIES.
AND WE'RE ON TRACK TO CLEAN OUR
THOUSAND HOME THIS SUMMER.
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED TWENTY NINE OF
THE FORTY SIX OR FORTY SIX
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ANOTHER
THIRTEEN ARE IN PROGRESS.
AND THE FUNDING TO IMPROVE
PERMITTING PROCESSES AND IT HAS
ENABLED US TO MAKE MORE TIMELY
AND ENFORCEABLE PERMIT DECISIONS.
ELEVEN DURING FISCAL YEARS
FISCAL YEAR.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THESE ARE
JUST A FEW HIGHLIGHTS TO GIVE
YOU A SENSE OF OUR PROGRESS.
THAT SAID.
DURING OUR JANUARY JOIN
OVERSIGHT HEARING WE TALKED
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S
ORGANIZATIONAL TRANSPARENCY AND
BUDGETARY CHALLENGES.
I REMAIN FOCUSED ON THESE ISSUES
AND CONTINUE TO BE PLEASED BY
OUR PROGRESS.
CHIEF DEPUTY NEGRI AND NINE AND
THE ENTIRE EXECUTIVE TEAM ARE
COMMITTED TO TACKLING ARE
PROBLEMS OF COURSE NOTHING
HAPPENS OVERNIGHT.
AND WILL BE PUBLISHING A NEW
STRATEGIC PLAN IN THE NEAR
FUTURE.
SO THAT YOU HAVE THE PUBLIC CAN
HAVE VISIBILITY INTO OUR PATH
FORWARD.
THE INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANELS
FIVE MAIN PRIORITIES ALIGNED
WITH THE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES OF
THAT STRATEGIC PLAN.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEPARTMENT'S
LONG STANDING STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
HAS REACHED A POINT WHERE WE
MUST NOW RELY ON GENERAL FUND
MONIES.
THE REQUESTED GENERAL FUND BACK
FILL OF TWENTY SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY AND EIGHTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION FOR THE
FOLLOWING TWO FISCAL YEARS.
WILL GIVE US TIME TO WORK WITH
YOU THE GOVERNOR.
AND OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO
IDENTIFYING A SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING SOLUTION.
THIS REQUEST ALSO ENABLES US TO
ACHIEVE GREATER BUDGET
TRANSPARENCY AND INCLUDES THE
ELIMINATION.
OF THE GENERAL FUND LOAN
REPAYMENT FROM THE LEAD ACID
BATTERY CLEAN UP FRONT.
FREEING UP THOSE REVENUES TO BE
USED FOR CLEANING CONTAMINATED
SITES AROUND FORMER LEAD ACID
BATTERY FACILITIES.
WHEN WE WERE BEFORE YOU IN
JANUARY WE UPDATED YOU ON OUR
EFFORTS TO GET OUR FINANCIAL
HOUSE IN ORDER?
WE DISCUSS THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING ACCURATE INFORMATION ON
BUDGET AND WORKLOAD WHICH UP
UNTIL THAT POINT HAD PROVED
QUITE ELUSIVE. TO ENSURE THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR AND ANY FEE
REFORMS.
WE MADE FURTHER FURTHER PROGRESS
ON OUR FISCAL GOVERNANCE WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS
INCLUDING FISCALE IN THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. TO STAY ON
TRACK FOR AN ON TIME YEAR END
CLOSING.
AND THE AUDIT WE MENTIONED IS
NOW IS UNDER WAY.
WE'RE CONTINUING OUR WORKLOAD
STUDY AND WILL SOON RELEASE A
STRATEGIC PLAN WITH PERFORMANCE
METRICS FOR EACH OF THE
DEPARTMENTS.
GRAMS. FOR TRANSPARENCY OUR
PERFORMANCE AGAINST KHIMETRICS
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON OUR NEWLY
UPDATED WEBSITE.
COLLECTIVELY THESE EFFORTS WILL
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION NEEDED
TO DETERMINE THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING REQUIRED TO DELIVER
MISSION.
THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
FOUNDATIONAL TO THE WORK OF A
FEW TASK FORCE PER THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
WE ARE COLLABORATING WITH THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO
DETERMINE WHAT ORGANIZATIONAL
AND FISCAL REFORMS ARE NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THE DEPARTMENT
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
PROVIDES ADEQUATE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AGAINST TOXIC SUBSTANCES.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
DOES LA -- OR SHOP SHAMA WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE%
YEAH -- WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE REQUEST
FOR TWENTY SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND THE
OTHER BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY HOWEVER
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT.
REQUESTS FOR EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO IN RECENT YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT
OF NUMEROUS LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS.
I DO TO FISCAL DIFFICULTIES IN
ALSO OPERATIONAL CONCERNS THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
APPROVING ONLY WHEN YOU'RE A
GENERAL FUND BACK FILL WILL
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO COME
BACK NEXT YEAR AS PART OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO
ADDRESS THE SHORTFALLS IN THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT.
THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ACCOUNT.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THERESA KELLER WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I AM WE HAD AS WAS
MENTIONED PROPOSED A MULTI YEAR
PLAN FOR THIS FUNDING GIVEN.
THAT FEE REVENUES WOULD TAKE A
WHILE TO MATERIALIZE -- BUT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE ALSO THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE FUNDING
OF THE STRUCTURE WILL BE ON
GOING SO -- WE APPRECIATE THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR FUNDING TO MAINTAIN CURRENT
OPERATIONS WITH REGARD TO THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON LANGUAGE
WE SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF COURSE
OF IMPROVING TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ABSENT LANGUAGE
IT'S HARD FOR US TO COMMENT ON
THE SPECIFICS BUT SUPPORTING THE
CONCEPT OF TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY IN.
THIS AREA [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- A LET ME ADD SOME
COMMENTS ANOTHER MAYBE --
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS --
OF FROM THE DYESS BUT WE'RE
WE'RE HERE TODAY WE HAD A TIME
WHEN THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT TO WHICH IS ONE OF THE
TSA'S.
MAIN ACCOUNTS IS PROJECTED TO BE
IN A DEFICIT -- IN THIS BUDGET
YEAR -- AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
OTHER MAN ACCOUNT THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL COUNT IS
PROJECTED TO BE INSOLVENT.
IN THE NEXT TWO OR THREE YEARS.
AND THE PROPOSAL BEFORE US IS
ESSENTIALLY ASKING FOR THE STATE
TO FILL IN THE COST OF THAT GAP
THAT SHOULD BE BORNE BY THE
REGULATORY REGULATED COMMUNITY.
THE DEPARTMENT'S DIFFICULTIES
LIKELY ARE -- I THINK WE KNOW
THERE RESULT OF MULTIPLE FACTORS
THOUGH UNDOUBTEDLY A MAJOR
FACTORS THE SHORTAGE OF FUNDING
FROM BOTH.
OF THESE TWO ACCOUNTS.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THE DTS THESE
PROBLEMS ARE NOT LIMITED TO
FISCAL ISSUES.
THE DEPARTMENT IS LONG FACED A
WIDE RANGE OF CRITICISMS
INCLUDING EXTREMELY LONG PERMIT
PROCESSING TIMES.
POR ENFORCEMENT DELAYED SITE
REMEDIATION AND AT TIMES OF
FAILURE TO RESPOND TO PUBLIC
CONCERNS.
NUMEROUS INTERNAL EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THE FUNCTIONING OF THE
TNC UNDER SEVERAL DIRECTORS HAS
NOT RESULTED AND SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN MANY RECOMMENDATIONS.
OF THE INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL
HAVE STILL NOT BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
EVEN ADEQUATE FUNDING.
I IS NOT.
A THE ONLY SOLUTION THAT WILL
IMPROVE DTS SEES DECISION MAKING
OR MAKE THEIR DECISIONS MORE
TRANSPARENT.
AND SO ALONG WITH APPROVING --
THIS GAP FUNDING FOR ONE YEAR.
OF THIS COMMITTEE IS PROPOSING A
SUITE OF CHANGES TO THE
DEPARTMENT THAT IS AIMED AT
IMPROVING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY.
AFFECT OF REGULATION OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE IS ESSENTIAL FOR
THE PROTECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THIS REALLY CANNOT WAIT ANY
LONGER -- ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
MR FONG FOLLOWED BY OTHERS REST.
A JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON WITH THE
CHAIRMAN HAD SAID WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE RESTRUCTURING.
CONCEPTS ARE IDEAS THAT ARE
BEING DISCUSSED IF YOU COULD
SHED SOME LIGHT AND AS A WHAT'S
BEING DONE TO KIND OF DEAL WITH
THE STRUCTURAL ISSUES.
THAT EXISTS WITHIN THE AGENCY.
I WOULD SAY AT THIS POINT WE'RE
STILL IN HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION ON ON
STRUCTURE BUT IT WOULD IT WOULD.
INCLUDE SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
OFFER BY THE INDEPENDENT REVIEW
PANEL AS WELL AS LOOKING AT HOW
WE'RE ORGANIZED -- IN TERMS OF
OUR PROGRAMS AND AND AND OUR
STOPPING LEVELS AND INSURING
THAT -- WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE
MIDDLE OF CONDUCTING A WORKLOAD
ANALYSIS -- THAT WORKLOAD
ANALYSIS IS GOING TO ASSIST US
WITH IDENTIFYING GAPS IN WHERE
WERE ABLE TO MEET YOUR STATUTORY
MANDATES AND WE'RE WE'RE NOT IN
SOME OF THE RESTRUCTURING WILL
BE TIED TO THE THE RESULTS OF
THAT ANALYSIS.
SO ARE THERE SOME THINGS THAT
YOU AGREE WITH THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ADD THAT YOUR THE
WORKING ON IMPLEMENTING OR YOU
GONNA WAIT.
I GUESS UNTIL.
SOMETHING GETS THE I MEAN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT WHAT YOU WAITING
FOR BUT I GUESS IN TERMS OF
GETTING SOMETHING IN IN THE
PROCESS OF BEING MOVED MOVING
ALONG TO TO TO RESTRUCTURE.
IF YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE THE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL I WOULD
SAY THAT WERE ABSOLUTELY
CONSIDERING ALL THOSE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE PAL HAS
MADE AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO HAVE A VERY CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR WORKLOAD
AND WHAT RESOURCES WE ARE A SIGN.
OR OR THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
USING FOR SPECIFIC STATUTORY
MANDATES TO UNDERSTAND -- WHAT
RESOURCE -- REQUIREMENTS WOULD
BE TIED TO THOSE RESTRUCTURED.
THAT THE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
RESTRUCTURE THAT THE INDEPENDENT
REVIEW PANEL MADE AND SO --
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
CONDUCTING THAT ANALYSIS AND
WERE ON SCHEDULED TO CONCLUDE
THAT ANALYSIS BY THE FALL.
I GUESS MY CONCERN IS MAYBE THE
LA -- CAN CHIME IN HERE TOO IS
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE DOING
A ONE TIME.
A LITTLE THE WHAT THAT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IS IS THERE'S
GONNA BE A ONE TIME BACK FILL
BUT THEN.
I MEAN IT'S IS THAT POPULATE THE
THAT YOU'RE GONNA COME BACK NEXT
YEAR OR THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
BACK FILL SOMETHING.
IF SOMETHING'S NOT HAPPENING OR
WHAT WERE THERE'S NOT A OF THE
PROCES MOVING FORWARD TO
ACTUALLY GET -- DGSE OF FROM
UNDER THE THE THE THE SITUATION
BEING INSOLVENT -- I GUESS
THAT'S THE LIE LARGER CONCERN
THAT I SHARE WITH THE CHAIRMAN
IS.
IS THERE REALLY A PLAN TO GET
OUT OF INSOLVENCY NEXT YEAR AND
THE YEAR FOLLOWING.
IT SHOULD SHOULD WE IDENTIFY THE
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES REQUIRED
THAT AND KNOW WHAT FEE STRUCTURE
WOULD BE REQUIRED.
TO TO CREATE ADEQUATE REVENUE.
THERE WILL BE A TIME.
IT WILL TAKE TIME TO GET THOSE
FEES IN PLACE TO TALK TO OUR
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT WHATEVER FREE
FOR PROPOSALS WE PUT FORTH.
AND THEN OF COURSE OBVIOUSLY TO
TO BRING THAT -- ANY FEE
PROPOSALS BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE'S SO IT IS.
HIGHLY UNLIKELY THAT WE WOULD
SEE REVENUE FROM A NEW FREE
STRUCTURE.
IN THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
MAYBE THE LA -- CONVENE CHIME IN
IN TERMS OF SURE OF THAT.
AND SO WHEN I LOOK AT THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION THE AGENDA THEY
RATED DOT TO PLACE HOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. TO CREATE
A FEW TASK FORCE WHICH IS
INTENDED I BELIEVE TO ADDRESS
ISSUES REGARDING THE FEE AND
ESTABLISH A FEE STRUCTURE THAT
WILL SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS IN
THE LONG TERM IT'S A HAZARDOUS
WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT.
THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ACCOUNT HOWEVER.
THAT I THINK THERE'S A
REALIZATION AND IT'S GONNA TAKE
OF THAT WORKING GROUP AWHILE TO
COME TO A CONSENSUS.
AND THEN ADOPT THE WHATEVER FEES
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO AGREE UPON --
SO THERE IS THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
IN FUTURE YEARS THERE WILL BE
ADDITIONAL NEEDS TO BACK FILL.
ON THESE FUNDS IN ORDER TO FOR
THEM TO MAINTAIN SALT.
AND TO TO FINITARY MAIN SOLVENT --
AND THEN IT REGARDING THE
THEY'RE LOOKING AT OTHER OPTIONS
HERE RESTRUCTURING DGSE TO
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN DECISION
MAKING I DON'T HAVE ANY DETAILS
ON THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND
WHAT SPECIFICALLY THAT WOULD
ENTAIL.
AN HOUR BUT WITH ALL THE SIX IT
ALSO LOOKS AS THOUGH WE'LL BE
DOING A CONNECTING TO STEADY
POTENTIALLY ON HOW TO
RESTRUCTURE THE SAFETY CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROMINENT WILL GRAMS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY HOUSED.
IN DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND
HOPEFULLY CHIEF IDENTIFY SOME
EFFICIENCIES THAT COULD BE
ACHIEVED THERE.
SO THE OF I'M AND READING
BETWEEN THE LINES -- YOUR
ANALYSIS PROBABLY INDICATES THAT --
THE THE INSOLVENCY PART AND THE
STRUCTURAL CHANGES WILL.
THE WON'T FIT BE IT WILL BE
DEALING WITH THIS SITUATION NEXT
YEAR.
AND THE YEAR AFTER PROBABLY MOST
LIKELY.
I THINK THERE'S A LIKELIHOOD
THAT THAT WILL THAT WILL HAPPEN
YES AND THAT THERE WILL BE A
NEED. TO TO PROVIDE SOME GENERAL
FUND TO BACK FILL THESE TWO
FUNDS IN THE FUTURE.
IS THERE ANY TALK OF A MAYBE
THAT IS THERE ANY TALK OF OF OF
NOT AB OF TRYING TO FIX THESE
CHALLENGES -- TO NOT HAVE TO DO
THIS NEXT YEAR I MEAN IS IT
POSSIBLE TO GET THIS FUND
SOLVENT BETWEEN. TO NOW NEXT
YEAR OR AND ARE NOW JUST A
POSSIBLE.
I THINK WITH THE TIMING AND THE
AND THE BUT THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL ENVISIONED WAS KIND OF
THE THREE YEARS RIGHT THAT IT
WOULD BE -- THAT FUNDING IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND DURING THAT
THE SUBSEQUENT TWO YEARS WHICH
IS WHAT THAT MAY REVISION
PROPOSED IT WOULD THERE WOULD BE
TIME AND NEEDED TO PUT.
A NEW FEE SCHEDULE PLACE
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT BOTH OF THE FUNDS I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF WAS THE
RECOGNITION THAT THIS IS KIND OF
A LONGER -- A LONGER TIME LINE.
TO TO PUT FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
MISTER YEAH UNFORTUNATELY I
THINK THERE'S A TIME LINE OF
OFFER GETTING ANY KIND OF FEE
RESTRUCTURING DONE THAT'S PART
OF THE PROBLEM HERE IT'S SO
WE'RE NOW -- A ROUGHLY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS -- POST THE INDEPENDENT
REVIEW PANEL'S RECOMMENDATIONS
AND WE'RE SITTING HERE LOOKING
AT A A DEFICIT -- MOVING FORWARD
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
OTHER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT --
WILL BE RELEASED IN THE NEXT --
OF VERY SHORT TO OF GOD THE NEXT
FEW DAYS -- WILL PROVIDE
LANGUAGE SHOP FOR IMPROVING
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
AND DECISION MAKING.
ON THOSE THINGS HOWEVER GOING TO
BE IF THEY'RE ADOPTED IN THE
BUDGET ARE GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE NEAR TERM
THANK IN A WAIT.
OF UP FOR THE FUTURE MITHRAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- GOING
BACK TO THE FEES.
YOU STEPPED UP AND BEEN
INCREASED IN ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
IS THAT CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT.
SO IN TWENTY YEARS THERE'S BEEN
NO EFFORT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO PUT TOGETHER FREE HE
STRUCTURE THAT IS GOING TO HELP
THE DEPARTMENT GET OUT FROM
UNDER ALL OF THIS HAS THEIR?
WE'VE ACTUALLY DONE A FAIR
AMOUNT OF ANALYSIS I THINK ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES FOR US IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE ALIGNED WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE IT'S BEEN ALL THAT NEEDS
TO BE OFFERED.
NO OVER THE COURSE OF THAT
TWENTY YEARS THERE'S BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THAT HASN'T BEEN ALIGNED
WITH THE ADJUSTMENTS AND SO WE
HAVE TO TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN WE COME UP WITH THE FLICK
BUT I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
AND CLEARLY WE HAD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND WE'VE
ALREADY BEEN ABLE TO DISCUSS ALL
OF OUR DEEP DEEP CONCERN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT IN ALL OF THE THE
FAILING SO YOU YOU YOU ARE THE
ACTIVE DIRECTORY YOU'RE YOU'RE
COMING IN. TO A SERIOUS PROBLEM
THE DIRECTOR TALKED ABOUT -- WHO
WAS THE GENTLEMAN WHO WHO SPOKE
THE SECTOR?
SECRETARY BLUNT.
AND HE ASSURED US THAT WE WOULD
BE MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WHAT ONE OF THE COMMENTERS MADE
IS THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON
PUTTING TOGETHER A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING?
OF YOUR WORK LOAD.
HOW'S THE LEGISLATURE GIVES
ADDITIONAL WORK -- PASSES
LEGISLATION.
THAT'S INCREASING YOUR WORKLOAD
AT SOME POINT SOMEBODY HAS TO
SAY WE NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT BUT IF
NOBODY IS REVIEWING OR IT SEEMS
THAT NOBODY IS REVIEWING.
WHO IS IT THAT LOOKS TO SEE WHAT
THE WORK LOAD IS WHETHER YOU CAN
DO IT WHETHER YOU CAN AFFORD IT
RATHER THAN WAIT UNTIL?
YOU'RE.
IN THE RED AND WE HAVE SO MANY
STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS WITH THIS
WHO REFUSE THIS. FOR ANY FOR ANY
LEGISLATION THAT GOES THROUGH WE
DO AN ANALYSIS OF THE IMPACT ON
THE DEPARTMENT IN TERMS OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S RESOURCES.
AND AFTERNOON THAT I'M SORRY
AFTER AN ANALYSIS IS DONE.
I ASSUME THERE'S A CONCLUSION
THAT'S REACHED AND WITH THE
CONCLUSION IS REACHED WHY DO WE
WAIT TWENTY YEARS BEFORE WE'RE
EVEN TALKING OR PUTTING TOGETHER.
A FEE INCREASE.
THERE ISN'T ENOUGH MONEY AND IT
EVERY YEAR IT'S A REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL MONEY TO BACK FILL
AND ONCE AGAIN THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL REQUEST.
I I ACTUALLY AGREE WITH THE LA --
ABOUT DOING THIS FOR JUST A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME THAN
PUTTING TOGETHER THE FEE TASK
FORCE.
BUT IT JUST SEEMS THAT THERE
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT IF
SOMEBODY IS REVIEWING THIS
INTERNALLY THEY WOULD BE LOOKING
TO SEE.
WHERE THE PROBLEMS ARE AND WHY
IT IS THAT WE CAN'T?
BE IN THE BLACK IN THIS WHY IS
IT THAT WE ARE ALWAYS IN IT IN A
DEFICIT AND TO CONTINUE TO GROW
IT ISN'T SOMETHING THAT JUST
HAPPENED THIS YEAR.
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
CLEARLY THE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
SOMETHING BUT I JUST I CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT THE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A HE THE MIRACULOUS FIX TO
THIS.
THIS IS VERY DEEP VERY VERY VERY
TROUBLING THE WAY THIS IS
CONTINUE TO GO THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PIECES OF LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR. TO TRY TO WORK ON
THIS THE THE GOVERNOR VETOED THE
BILL'S SAYING HE WOULD EXPECTED
THE DEPARTMENT TO TO WORK THEM
OUT.
AND HERE WE ARE STILL WITH THE
SAME PROBLEMS.
I AM I I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY IS THE
PRIMARY REASON FOR THE DELAYS IN
PROCESSING PERMITS?
I AM I WOULD ACTUALLY SAY THAT
WE'VE DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB IN
IMPROVING THE THE LENGTH OF TIME
IT TAKES FOR PERMIT DECISIONS.
IF YOU LOOK AT NINE PERMIT
DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE I
BELIEVE IN A FISCAL YEAR.
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE AVERAGE
TIME TO MAKE THOSE PERMIT
DECISIONS WAS TWENTY THREE
MONTHS AND THAT'S IN DIRECT
CONTRAST TO THE AVERAGE OF FOUR
YEARS THAT IT USED TO TAKE US TO
DO A PERMANENT.
AND WE'VE CONTINUED TO DECREASE
THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT TAKES TO
DO THE PERMITS.
WE HAVE WITH THE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES WE MAPPED OUT OF
COURSE TO BEING ABLE TO MAKE 90%
OF OUR PERMIT DECISIONS WITHIN
TWO YEARS AND WE BELIEVE WE HAVE
THE PROCESS IS IN PLACE.
AND THE STAFF TRAINING -- UNDER
WAY TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT SO
YOU'LL SEE YOU KNOW LAST YEAR WE
ISSUED ELEVEN PERMIT DECISIONS
WE THINK WILL ISSUE TWELVE
PERMIT THIS.
DECISIONS THIS YEAR ON THE WAY
TO GETTING TO SIXTEEN PERMIT
DECISIONS A YEAR.
AND SO WHAT WE ARE ON THE THE
THE RESOURCES WE'VE BEEN GIVEN
OVER THE YEARS TO ADDRESS OUR
PERMITTING -- ARE PERMITTING
CHALLENGES HAVE REALLY BORN A
LOT OF FRUIT IT'S NOT THAT
VISIBLE TO FOLKS BUT IN FACT WE
ARE MAKING MUCH MORE TIME WE
PERMIT DECISIONS.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE STAFF
RESOURCES.
YOU DO HAVE.
ALLOWS YOU TO BE CAPABLE OF
ADDRESSING THE CORE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT ARE SIGNED
TO THE TO THE DEPARTMENT.
AGAIN.
I WOULD REFER TO WHAT CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR DEGREES
MENTIONED WHICH IS THAT.
THERE ARE SOME GAPS AND WE KNOW
THERE'S SOME GAPS AND WE ARE
WORKING VERY HARD TO UNDERSTAND
WITH GREAT SPECIFICITY WHAT
THOSE GAPS ARE.
YOU KNOW WE KNOW.
I COULD SIT HERE AND TELL YOU A
COUPLE AREAS WHERE I THINK WE
MIGHT HAVE SOME CHALLENGES BUT
THE WORKLOAD ANALYSIS GIVES THIS
THAT DETAILED.
NUMERIC QUANTITATE QUANTIFIED
ANALYSIS OF WE'RE THOSE
CHALLENGES LIE AND WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THAT PROCESS WE WILL BE.
YOU KNOW MAKING GUESSES ABOUT
WATER RESOURCE REQUIREMENTS ARE.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY AT ANY
TIME WOULD WANT.
SUCH AN IMPORTANT DEPARTMENT TO
BE GUESSING.
BUT WE CERTAINLY WOULD EXPECT.
THAT AFTER ALL THESE YEARS THAT
WE WOULD HAVE MORE THAN GUESSING.
DOES THE DEPARTMENT HAVE THE
PERSONAL CAPACITY TO DO.
WHAT YOU BEEN ASKED TO DO?
THAT'S THE ONE I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT -- WHERE ARE WE ARE AS WE
GO THROUGH INCOMPLETE EACH
PROGRAM AND LOOK AT -- THE
CURRENT STOPPING LEVELS THE
WORKLOAD YOU KNOW AS SIGNED TO
THOSE PROGRAMS WERE BEGINNING TO
SEE SOME GAPS BUT WE NEED THE
ENTIRE WE NEED TO COMPLETE THE
ENTIRE WORKLOAD ANALYSIS TO SEE.
WHETHER OR NOT WE HAVE -- WE
HAVE DEFICIENCIES IN SOME AREAS
THAT COULD BE -- MANAGED BY RE
DIRECTION OF RESOURCES IN OTHER
AREAS AND SO THAT'S WHY IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO SAY.
PRELIMINARILY THAT WE HAVE A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF DEFICIT AT
THIS POINT PURSES WHEN WE
COMPLETE THE ANALYSIS WE SHOULD
HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY OF ALL OF OUR
RESOURCES ARE ALIGNED WITH OUR
MANDATES AND OUR STRATEGIC
PRIORITIES THAT WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF FINALIZING RIGHT NOW.
SO -- I'M NOT TRYING TO PASS OFF
THE ANSWER BUT I THINK IT WOULD
BE JUST A LITTLE BIT PREMATURE
TO SAY RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS EXTENSIVE
UNDER RESOURCING IS I DO EXPECT
SOME PROGRAMS TO BE.
THERE TO BE A GAP BETWEEN HOW
THE RESOURCE AND WHAT THEIR
MANDATES ARE AND I'D LIKE TO
COMPLETE THE ANALYSIS BEFORE WE
SAY THAT WE NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES RATHER THAN RE DIRECT.
AND YOU SAY THE YOU WILL
CONCLUDED THE ANALYSIS BY FALL
WE'RE ON TARGET FOR THAT
[inaudible]
AND AT DO YOU WOULD YOU AGREE
THAT IF AFTER FALL YOU COMPLETE
THIS ANALYSIS YOU PROVIDE US
YOUR RESPONSE AND IF YOU'RE
STILL IN IN IF IF IT'S STILL THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT.
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD ACCEPT THAT
THERE WOULD HAVE TO BE SOME
SERIOUS CHANGES AT THAT POINT.
WELL I'VE ONE APPOINTMENT IS
UNABLE TO DEAL WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITIES AT SOME POINT
THE HOUSE HAS TO BE SOME CHANGE
ABSOLUTELY I I WANT TO
DIFFERENTIATE -- BETWEEN DOING
THE WORKLOAD ANALYSIS AND THE
CURRENT BUDGET SITUATION THAT
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW WITH THE FEES
VERSES.
YOU KNOW THAT WHAT WE'RE
BRINGING IN VERSUS WHAT WE'RE
SPENDING WE KNOW THERE'S A
DEFICIT THERE THERE BEEN.
FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
JUST NOT EVEN -- MANDATES BUT IN
JUST THE COST OF A STATE
OPERATIONS OVER THE PAST FIVE TO
TEN YEARS SO.
THAT'S EXACERBATED THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT -- SO -- YES
THE WORKLOAD ANALYSIS WILL GIVE
US SOME INFORMATION BUT TODAY WE
DO KNOW THAT WE ARE NOT BRINGING
IN A SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF FEES
TO COVER OUR THE COST OF OF OUR
STATE OPERATIONS.
JUST FINALLY MISTER CHAIR YOU
SAY TODAY YOU KNOW ME.
CLEARLY ANYBODY WHO'S LOOKING
THIS HAS KNOWN THIS IS BEEN.
THE CASE FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND
YEARS THIS IS NOTHING NEW.
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
REALLY CONCERNED EVEN AFTER THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING EVEN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS -- POST -- OVER
THE REVIEW PANEL AND EVEN TO TO
TO GET SOME.
THE BEGINNINGS OF WHAT IS GOING
TO BE DONE TO CHANGE THIS AND I
I'M NOT HEARING ANYTHING BUT I
WILL BE GOING WITH WHAT THE
STAFF IS RECOMMENDING BUT I I
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT.
JUST THE WAY THE WHOLE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ANSWERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
AS GARCIA.
THANK YOU SO TO SPEAK FOR A
MISTER OF WITH -- MAKING SURE IN
THE SENSE THAT YOU EXPECT THAT
IN.
THE FALL YOU WILL HAVE A
STRATEGIC PLAN OF HOW TO REFORM
THE DEPARTMENT.
THE STRATEGIC PLAN WILL OUTLINE --
OUR WORK ACROSS OUR PROGRAM
STITCH TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
THE THE IMPROVE THE DEPARTMENT.
THE FEE PROPOSAL IS NOT EXPECT
ME IS IS DELIVERABLE OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS REGION'S
STRATEGIC PLAN IT'S NOT WE DON'T
PUT FORTH THAT PROPOSAL IN THE
STRATEGIC PLAN.
THIS A AND I WOULD SAY THE
STRATEGIC PLAN WILL BE COMING
OUT IMMINENTLY IT'S IT'S IT'S AN
IT'LL BE BEFORE THE FALL
[inaudible]
AND SO.
WE'VE BEEN WE'VE HAD AN IRA P..
OUT THERE FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS
MINIATURE SAID WE'VE HAD BILLS
COME THROUGH HERE WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING -- SHORTCOMINGS WITH
PTSD FOR AWHILE EXCEPT HAS BEEN
AN EXAMPLE FOR US OF OF PLENTY
LESSONS FOR US LEARN OF OF WORK
WE NEED TO DO.
OUT THERE AND SO I'M NOT GOING
TO BE HELD WE HAVE TO FALL.
PART OF THE RECOMMENDATION
LOOKING HERE IS NOT JUST A ONE
TIME BACKFILL BUT ALSO SOME REAL
REFORM SAID DEPARTMENT.
AT IN ON THIS YEAR NOT NEXT YEAR.
LET ME PUT THAT ASIDE FOR A
SECOND AB HOW TO SAY SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THE
STRATEGIC PLAN SHOULD BE
IDENTIFYING SEPARATE FROM THE
FEE ISSUE WHAT WOULD BE SOME OF
THE THINGS YOU THINK WE NEED TO
BE WORKING.
ON SO. ONE OF THE OBVIOUS GOALS
OF THE STRATEGIC PLAN IS TO COME
UP WITH A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
MODEL FOR THE DEPARTMENTS OF
SIMILARLY WILL SET THAT ASIDE
BECAUSE IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING --
WE HAVE -- A SPECIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE US GOAL
BUILT INTO THAT STRATEGIC PLAN
AND A NUMBER OF OBJECTIVES THAT.
WILL CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN OUR
IN DROUGHT MEMBER MENTAL JUSTICE
WORK ANDA LOOK AT HOW WE CAN.
REMOTE EQUITY IN OUR DECISION
MAKING -- WE HAVE A GOAL AROUND
JUST PERFORMING OUR CORE
FUNCTIONS BEING MORE EFFICIENT
BRINGING THINGS MODERNIZED
MODERNIZING TOOLS AND PRACTICES.
OF DOING THINGS LIKE WORKING
WITH USEPA TO TAKE THEIR BEST
PRACTICES AROUND CLEAN UP AND
AND AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
USING BEST PRACTICES -- AS WE
PLAN AND IMPLEMENT OUR SITE
CLEANUPS AND SITE REMEDIATION --
YOU WILL SEE THINGS AROUND
COMMUNICATIONS HOW WILL WE
COMMUNICATE THAT WITH THING WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDERS MAKING IT MORE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE PROVIDING
MORE TRANSPARENCY.
ON THEIRS.
I COULD GO ON AND DO YOU WANT TO
ADD ANY JUST THAT THE THE PLAN
ITSELF -- IN IN INCORPORATES
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE BEEN
RECEIVING NOT ONLY FROM THE RP
BUT FROM OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS
AND OTHER FEEDBACK THAT WE
RECEIVED OVER THE YEARS AND
WE'VE BEEN.
ACTUALLY I'M SPECIFICALLY
MAPPING THE ACTION ITEMS THE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES TO THAT BE
BACK IN AND PLAN TO DO PUBLIC
OUTREACH WITH THE PLAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S RESPONSIVE.
TO OUR COMMUNITY PARTNER
CONCERNED CENTER OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS CONCERNS.
I ANSWER THAT QUESTION BECAUSE
THEY WE KNOW WE WE'VE BEEN
ASKING THE SAME CONSTANTLY.
OF WHAT ARE THE CHANCES WE NEED
TO DO AND AND WE TALKED ABOUT
HOW WE NEED TO STREAMLINE THE
PERMITTING PROCESS.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT INCLUDING
MORE EQUITY AND COMMUNITY BEING
PART OF THAT -- THE FEE
STRUCTURES.
AT THE END OF THE DAY AT MY
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS KEEPING
PEOPLE HEALTHY AND I HAVE A
COMMUNITY THAT'S BEEN.
PLACE AND WITH MANY THINGS OUT
THERE MANY TOXICS OUT THERE.
ON AND WORK THAT'S TRYING TO GET
DONE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ENGAGING HAVE BEEN VERY VOCAL
ABOUT WHAT THEY WANT FOR AWHILE
NOW.
IN SO WORRIES ME THAT WE'RE
GOING TO SPEND ANOTHER THREE
YEARS COMING UP WITH THE PLAN
THAT THEN WE WILL IMPLEMENT.
VERSUS WE'VE HAD SO MUCH
INFORMATION THAT FROM A
DISCUSSION THAT I THINK WE COULD
DO SOME KEY PILLARS OF THAT
REFORM NOW. TO MAKE SURE THAT
ADDS THAT GETS MOVED IN
IMPLEMENTED MAYBE IF I TAKE A
YEAR MOVIES I TAKE TWO YEARS BUT
IF WE WAIT TO ADOPT THAT THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE THOSE YEARS PLUS
WHATEVER IT IS TO IMPLEMENT THAT.
IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE
COMMUNITIES I CONTINUE TO BE
PLACED IN THE CONTINUE TO BE
SICK OUT THERE.
I THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION OUT THERE TO BE ABLE --
TO PASSING REFORMS NOW I TO
ESTABLISH SCHOOLS AROUND EQUITY
AROUND FEE STRUCTURES -- AROUND
PERMITTING AROUND MAKING SURE
NOT ONLY THAT WE'RE PERMITTING
BUT WE'RE RETURNING TO THE SITE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THINGS
ACTUALLY BEING FOLLOWED OR MAYBE
THERE'S IMPROVEMENTS ON THE ROAD
THAT WE CAN NOW IMPLEMENT.
ALONG THE WAY AND SO I THINK WE
HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION AT THIS
POINT WE HAD ENOUGH THE
DISCUSSIONS.
I UNDERSTAND THERE YOUR HAVE A
MINUTE LONG I UNDERSTAND THAT
ARE GOVERNOR HASN'T BEEN THERE
THAT LONG BUT I FEEL LIKE.
THAT THAT'S NOT ENOUGH OF A
REASON NOT TO TAKE ACTION THIS
YEAR ON AND NOT TO START TO MOVE
THINGS FORWARD I THINK HAVING A
BUDGET.
BACK FILL FOR ONE YEAR AND THE
REALITIES THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO THIS AGAIN ALLOWS US
TO COME BACK AND SAY WHAT HAVE
WE DONE THIS YEAR FOR REALS AND
WHAT THE NEXT THE BERGEN TO TAKE.
I SAID A THING LET'S HAVE
EVERYTHING FIGURED OUT BECAUSE
NO MATTER WHAT TIME WE COME UP
WITH FOR HUMAN BEINGS IS NOT
GOING TO BE A PERFECT PLAN.
BUT I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
HEALTH.
ENTER THE COMMUNITIES AND TERMS
OF GENERATIONS OF KIDS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE SIX GENERATIONS
THAT MAYBE WE COULD STOP SOONER.
OUT THERE AND SO FOR ME I I A
SUPPORT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION --
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE TRAILER
BILL OUT THERE -- AND I HOPE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE DEPARTMENT.
OF TOXINS IN THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE COULD COME UP
WITH SOME SOLUTIONS THIS YEAR TO
MOVE TO MOVE THIS FORWARD TO AND
NOT WAIT.
ANY FURTHER AND I HOPE THAT WE
ARE TAKING THE LESSONS LEARNED I
APPRECIATE THE STEPPING BACK ON
THE LOAN FROM THE DEBATE THE
BATTERY FEET TO HELP.
A PIECE OF BACK I APPRECIATE --
THAT WE ARE DISCUSSING THE WORK
WE'VE DONE I THINK IN THE
DISCUSSION WE COULD EVEN TALK
ABOUT THE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR LOANS.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT SHOULD
BE ALONE I SHOULD BE A GIFT AT
SOME POINT ON AND AND MOVE
FORWARD SOMETHING THAT.
IS THE LEAST WE COULD DO FOR FOR
THESE COMMUNITY SO WE'RE NOT
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION IS I
THINK THAT THERE HAS BEEN SOME.
POSITIVES THIS FORD BUT I WILL
SAY HAVING BEEN HERE NOW
DISCUSSING THIS FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS I DON'T SEE WHY.
WE NEED TO WAIT TILL FALL I
DON'T SEE WHY WE CAN'T DO
SOMEBODY'S BIGGER STRUCTURAL
CHANGES NOW -- I SEEK FOLKS IN
THE COMMUNITY HERE HAVE BEEN
PRETTY WELL CAN I THINK HAVE
GIVEN US AND CARE THAT DIRECTION
OF THINGS THAT WE COULD BE DOING.
NOW TO TO WORKING -- FOR AND SO
I JUST WANTED TO REMEMBER THAT
IT'S HUMAN HEALTH.
AND PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING SICK
RIGHT NOW AND I GETTING SICKER
AND IT'S COMPOUNDED AND THOSE
KIDS THAT ARE GONNA BE BORN INTO
THIS AND THAT IF WE WAIT THREE
YEARS MORE.
ON THAT WE ARE AFFECTING THEIR
DEVELOPMENT EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY [inaudible]
MS RIVAS.
I'M FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR THE WORK THAT IN
PREPARING THIS THOROUGH REPORT --
YOU KNOW WE ALL WANT TO SEE
CHANGE FROM DTS CA.
AND WILL BE PAINTED CLOSE
ATTENTION TO PROGRESS YOU KNOW I
SHARE THE SENSE OF URGENCY FROM
MY COLLEAGUES ON BECAUSE I THINK
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
IMPACTED IN A PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR -- UNITIES
THAT ARE WAITING TO HEAR FROM US
WHAT WE ARE DOING -- YOU KNOW TO
MAKE PROGRESS ON THIS ISSUE --
AND SO.
THAT'S WILL.
WHERE I AM COMING FROM AND I
HOPE THAT?
NEXT YEAR WHEN YOU COME BACK
THAT WE WILL HEAR.
AT LEAST SOME PROGRESS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ON AT LEAST ONE THING.
THAT YOU HAVE CHANGED -- SO
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO SET A HIGHER
BAR.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE SIDE OF GET UP GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS INGRID
ROSTRUM AND WHAT THE SAN ANDREAS
POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT AND
WE'VE SPOKEN MANY TIMES.
AT OVERSIGHT HEARINGS BUDGET
HEARINGS AND COMMITTEE HEARINGS
ON THE CHASSIS AND THE NEED FOR
REFORM I JUST WANTED TO START
WITH A FEW PRINCIPLES -- ONE IS
THAT ANY PROGRAMMATIC REDUCTIONS
ULTIMATELY IS GOING TO HARM
COMMUNITIES.
SO WE DO BELIEVE THAT DETAILS HE
MUST CONTINUE ON ITS VITAL
PROGRAMS AND PERMITTING AND
ENFORCEMENT AND CLEAN UPS.
SECONDLY.
THE POLLUTER PAYS PRINCIPLES.
ARE WE DESPERATELY NEED FEE
REFORM AND WE NEED TO HAZARDOUS
WASTE INDUSTRIES -- AND THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE GENERATORS AND
THE AND AND THAT THAT THE FOLKS
THAT DISPOSE OF HAZARDOUS WASTE.
TO BE PAYING. FOR THE COST OF
THIS AGENCY RATHER THAN MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHICH IS WHAT IS
BEING ASKED I DO.
ON THERE FOR A WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS MIGHT BE A
STOP GAP -- MEASURE FOR THIS
YEAR -- IT MUST NOT BE A BLANK
CHECK.
WE NEED -- CONDITIONS WE NEED
BENCHMARKS ON FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS A REAL IMPROVEMENT ATTACHED
TO THIS.
BLANK CHECK THAT IS BEING ASKED.
FOR THIS YEAR -- WE REALLY NEED
THIS AGENCY TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT MORE COUNTABLE AND
MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE
COMMUNITY'S WE'VE BEEN.
OF PARROTING THIS PHRASE A LOT
OVER THE YEARS BUT IT IT REALLY
MEANS SOMETHING.
ON WE HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR A
GOVERNING BOARD OR OR OVERSIGHT
BOARD IN THE ABSENCE OF THE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL
COMMUNITIES HAVE NOWHERE TO GO --
TO FOR THAT LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT
OTHER THAN THE LEGISLATURE AND
FRANKLY THAT'S NOT YOUR JOB
[inaudible]
ARM.
IN TERMS OF A AS WE TALKED ABOUT
FUNDING GAPS I DO WANT TO ALERT --
AT THE MEMBERS HERE ARE THAT
ALREADY THIS PRO THIS DEPARTMENT
HAS NOT FULFILLED SOME BASIC
THINGS IN TWENTY TWELVE THE
POLLUTION PREVENTION PROGRAM AT
THE TNC GOT CUT BECAUSE OF LACK
OF FUNDING.
SO AS WE START LOOKING AT BIG
PICTURE REFORMS WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THE BIGGER PICTURE IN TERMS
OF WHAT IS IN OUR FUTURE IF WE
DON'T START REDUCING THE AMOUNT
OF HAZARDOUS WASTE.
THAT WE CREATE -- WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE TYPES OF
DISCUSSIONS WE WOULD LIKE THE
POLLUTION PREVENTION PROGRAM TO
BE REFUNDED INCLUDED IN IN IN
THE FEE STRUCTURE CONVERSATIONS
THAT STEM FROM THIS.
ARM THE STATE WHAT HAZARDOUS
WASTE MANAGEMENT PLAN -- THE
LEGISLATURE ORDER THAT DONE IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
NINETEEN NINETIES IT WAS NEVER
DONE.
AS A STATE WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
WE'RE GOING WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH WASTE IS BEING GENERATED
AND WHERE AND WHERE IT'S GOING
TO BE CITED AND LOCATED.
SO THAT'S ANOTHER THING THAT WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT AS WE THINK
ABOUT THESE LONGER TERM
SOLUTIONS.
AND FINALLY WERE -- FIFTY FOUR
BACK FILLING AND FILLING THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT
BUT IT WE NEED TO ALSO PAY
ATTENTION TO THE TOSCA ACCOUNT.
ON I THINK THE STAFF REPORTS
HAVE NOTED FOR THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS THAT THE DEFICIT IS
IMPENDING -- I WOULD SAY THAT
THE DECEPTIVE BECAUSE IT IS
ALREADY HERE. FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS -- DTS CD HAS
ONLY BEEN ABLE TO FIND ABOUT
HALF OF THE ORPHAN SITE CLEANUPS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT MEANS THAT
OTHER HALF.
OF THAT CONTAMINATION IS
SPREADING AND IS GOING TO COST
THE TAXPAYERS AND THE STATE MORE
MONEY AS WELL OF COURSE ON THE
ULTIMATE.
PRICE WHICH IS WITH PRICES TO
HUMAN HEALTH ALSO.
IN THIS CONVERSATION ALSO SHOULD
NOT BE HAPPENING ABSENT A BIG
LOOK AT TOSCA AND WHAT ARE WE
GONNA DO ABOUT OUR CEANUP
OBLIGATIONS AND SPECIFICALLY
THOSE OR FRANCE ACT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS AN OF US BECAUSE I'M
HERE BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RUNS
JUST SLANT SENATE FIRST ONE ECHO
THE COMMENTS FOR MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SYRUPY.
BUT ALSO ONE ECHO -- JUST THE
FACT THAT YOU JUST SEEN A
BIPARTISAN EFFORTS AND THE
QUESTIONS OF FOLKS HAVE BEEN
ASKING IT'S REALLY IT'S
REFRESHING TO HEAR -- WE'VE BEEN
HERE FOR A COUPLE YEARS ASKING
FOR THE SAME THINGS I THINK YOU
KNOW SOME ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN HERE ASKING FOR A LITTLE
SIMILAR THINGS ANYTHING FOR US
IS REALLY HOW DO WE ARE
INTENTIONAL PARTNERS A MOVIE FOR
IT BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHATEVER
HAPPENS THIS YEAR'S NOT.
REALLY GOING TO FIX REALLY WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS AND HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY BECOME.
REALLY THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
CAN ACTUALLY HELP YOU THROUGHOUT
THAT COME COUPLE YEARS BECAUSE I
KNOW SEEN THAT REPORT THAT.
ON THE COMMITTEE STAFF PUT
TOGETHER IT YOU KNOW THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE ACCOUNT IS GOING
TO BE IN A DEFICIT TWENTY SEVEN
YOU KNOW. TWENTY FIVE MILLION
THIS YEAR -- BUT THEN AS
SUGGESTED FORTY FOUR MILLION IN
NEXT YEAR AND THEN THE THIRTY IS
GOING TO BE SIXTY FIVE MILLION
BUT EVEN OF THE MONEY HAS BEEN
REQUESTED FROM DEPARTMENT NAMING
GOING TO BACK FILL US ACCOUNTS.
AND SPECIFIC PREVIOUS YEAR SO
REALLY LOOKING NOT NOT REALLY
FUNDING CURRENT STATUS BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IS REALLY THINKING ABOUT THIS
TRUCK PARTS TRANSFORMED ME.
AND MORE THAN AND BE HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY WE LOOK AT THIS.
IN THE SENSE OF WHO IS
ACCOUNTABLE TO HOMES ALLEGE
STRICTER HAS BEEN ACCOUNTABLE TO
THIS DEPARTMENT AND THE
STRUCTURAL CHANGE THAT WE NEED
BUT ALSO HOW DO WE EMBED A
COMMUNITY.
COMPONENT TO THIS AND ALSO A LOT
OF C. QUARTERS INCLUDING OUR
INDUSTRY PARTNERS WHICH YOU KNOW
SOME OF THEM WERE ALWAYS -- YOU
KNOW AN OPPOSITE ENDS BUT THIS
IS ISSUE THERE WERE PROBABLY THE
SAME SIDE ON SOME ITEMS.
IN THIS IS A RARE -- JUST VISUAL
TO ACTUALLY YOU KNOW WE'RE
ASKING FIRST TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM A DEPARTMENT
AND WE HAVEN'T BEEN GETTING ON
EITHER SIDE SO JUST REALLY
THINKING BE MINDFUL THAT I'M
REALLY LOOKING AT THE
LEGISLATURE IN BOTH
ADMINISTRATION TO SEE HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY SEE THIS.
AS SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T FIX
FOR THIS YEAR REALLY LOOKING AT
IT FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS
BECAUSE PERSONALLY I CAN BE
COMING BACK EVERY YEAR.
ASKING FOR THE SAME THING AND I
DON'T THINK I'M ASKING THAT FROM
A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS COR LITTLE
BIT EXHAUSTED OF ACTUALLY SEEING
THE SAME THING OVER AND OVER IN
A LOT OF IT.
IS YOU KNOW A LOT OF THESE
MEMBERS ACTUALLY.
YOU KNOW RESPONSIBLE TO HIS
CONSTITUENCY THOSE CONDITIONS HE
ARE ASKING FOR THE SAME THINGS
AND AND YOU KNOW AT LEAST WE CAN
GET SOME HOPE.
I'M AND WE'RE HOPING AFTER YOU
KNOW THE WORK ANALYSIS COMES OUT
THIS FALL.
ON BLISS I WAIT UNTIL THE FALL
TO ACTUALLY SEE SOMETHING IF WE
CAN ACTUALLY PUT IN PLACE THAT
CAN ACTUALLY DEVELOPING ACTUALLY
ADD TO THE WORKFORCE ANALYSIS
AND REALLY LOOKING AT THE FEE
STRUCTURE AND HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THAT SO.
WITHOUT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE ONLY COMPANY IN THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS -- BUT REALLY
GETTING THIS APARTMENT RIGHT
IT'S NOT FOR ME OR FOR ANYBODY
BUT IS REALLY WHAT WE NEED AND
ALSO LOOKING AT HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY DEAL WITH OUR WASTE.
MOVING FORWARD SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- IS IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION IS THERE A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON ISSUE ONE ON
ITEMS TO BE HEARD.
THEIR SECOND WHO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BLOOM.
HI FONG.
GARCIA HI.
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAY YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO ALSO UNDER THE TSC --
THAT WOULD BE A COST RECOVERY A
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
WE ARE REQUESTING A ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION OF A TWO POINT SIX
MILLION SPLIT BETWEEN EACH W. C.
A. N. TOSCA IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY AND SIX
POSITIONS FOR PERMANENT AND TO
LIMITED TERM. FOR THE PLANNING A
PROJECT PHASES OF THE COST
RECOVERY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM I. T.
PLATFORM UPGRADE PROJECT.
UPGRADING THE THIS PLATFORM IS
CRUCIAL BECAUSE THE EXISTING
SYSTEM IS NO LONGER SUPPORTED
CANNOT BE UPGRADED TO MEET.
A CHANGE IN STATUTE AND IS
SUBJECT TO SECURITY THREATS.
DTS HE RECOVERS MILLIONS IN
RESPONSE COSTS ANNUALLY FROM
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES AND
PERMITTED HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES AND THE COST RECOVERY
BILLING SYSTEM SUPPORTS THESE
ACTIVITIES.
THE NEW SYSTEM WILL PROVIDE THE
ABILITY TO TRACK AN ACCOUNT FOR
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS AUTOMATE
THE PROCESS FOR ISSUING
COLLECTION LETTERS TO BILLABLE
PARTY'S.
ACCOMMODATE MULTI TIERED
INTEREST RATES AS REQUIRED BY AB.
TWO SEVENTY THREE IMPROVE DTS
HE'S ABILITY TO IDENTIFY AND
REPORT ON DELINQUENT INVOICES
AND TIMELY ISSUE COLLECTION
LETTERS.
AND IMPROVE ON ONLINE
FUNCTIONALITY INCLUDING ENABLING
BILLABLE PARTIES THE ABILITY TO
VIEW OR RUN REPORTS THAT REFLECT
THEIR INVOICING OR PAYMENT
HISTORY.
IDOL IMPROVE THE OVERALL
FUNCTIONALITY INCLUDING THE
ABILITY TO QUICKLY RESEARCH
RECONCILING THE JUST COSTS.
IN FINALLY IT WILL IMPROVE COST
RECOVERY CASE MANAGEMENT AND
WORK FOR THE TRACK ACTIONS ON
SITES WITH UNREIMBURSED COSTS.
IN THE PAST THE LACK OF CASE
MANAGEMENT HAS HAMPERED
EFFECTIVE COST RECOVERY.
WE'VE CHOSEN A SOLUTION THAT
PROVIDES A CAT COST EFFECTIVE
KNOWN STRATEGY MEETS LEGISLATIVE
COST RECOVERY INTEREST RATES.
INTEREST RATE MANDATES OF AB TWO
SEVENTY THREE AN ALLIANCE WITH
CALLIE PA'S INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY STRATEGIC PLAN TO
LEVERAGE EXISTING TECHNOLOGY AND
SOLUTIONS.
AND FINALLY THE SELECTED
SOLUTION MINIMIZES SECURITY
THREATS.
THE PLANNING PHASE STAGE FOUR OF
THE PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
IS ESTIMATED TO BE COMPLETED IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY NINETEEN WE
WERE APPRECIATE THE
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE AS
PROPOSED AND ADOPTED BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD MAKE THE
RELEASE OF FUNDS CONTINGENT ON
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND%
FINANCE APPROVAL.
BUT WOULD ASK THAT 200-909-4000
DOLLARS BE IMMEDIATELY APPROVED
FOR THE COMPLETION OF STAGE FOR
WHICH IS ESTIMATED TO BE
COMPLETED IN AUGUST.
OF TWENTY NINETEEN I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS -- I WANTED TO
ASK FOR CLARIFICATION ON WHAT
YOU WERE ASKING FOR THESE OF THE
THE TWENTY TWO HUNDRED NINETY
FOUR THOUSAND YOU READ THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND THE STAFF
REPORT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
I THOUGHT WAS IT.
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
REFLECTS THAT ASK AND IT IS --
MOST OF THE REQUESTED THAT TO
NINETY FOUR IS BUDGETED AND THEN
THE TWO POINT TWO EIGHT FOUR
MILLION AS REFLECTED IN THE LA --
AND STAFF RECOMMENDATION WOULD
BE CONTINGENT I ASSUME THAT I
POLITICS I DIDN'T SEE THE TWO
NINETY FOUR SPELLED OUT SO.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE OF THAT
WAS CLEAR -- I THINK THE LA --
HAS SOME COMMENTS SHAMA WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
ENSURE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
WE'RE RECOMMENDING THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE THAT YOU SEE THERE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IN YOUR
AGENDA.
RIGHT ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MISS REYES.
MAYBE I'M MISSING SOMETHING BUT
WARRANT WE DEALING WITH UPDATING
A NO LONGER SUPPORTED.
SOFTWARE.
THAT IS TO TEN YEARS.
THE FOR TEN YEARS THIS IS BEEN.
OVER TEN YEARS LATER ON THIS
WHERE WE NOW.
JUST DEVELOPING A PROJECT PLAN
TO ADDRESS THIS.
I'M LIKE I CAN'T SPEAK -- TO
MMHM.
YOU KNOW LONG RANGE HISTORY BUT
I CAN SPEAK TO YOU KNOW WE
UNDERSTAND NOW THAT THE THE
SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE UPDATED AND
AND THAT WE NEED ADDITIONAL
FUNCTIONALITY IN ORDER TO MEET.
MEET OUR COST RECOVERY -- GOALS
AND AND PLANS AND SO AND WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGED IN THIS PROCESS FOR
A FEW YEARS ACTUALLY TO TO
UPDATE IT ACTUALLY -- SEVERAL
YEARS AGO IT WAS ANTICIPATED
THAT THE NEW THIS CAL SYSTEM
WOULD INCLUDE FUNCTIONALITY --
THAT WOULD -- ENABLE -- THAT
THAT THIS CAL SYSTEM TO TAKE
CARE OF THIS PARTICULAR AND
BUSINESS PROCESS FOR US AND ONCE
THERE WAS SOME ANALYSIS DONE IT
WAS DETERMINED THAT THE SCALP
COULDN'T -- INCLUDE THIS
PARTICULAR FUNCTIONALITY AND SO
WE BEGAN THE PROCESS THE PROJECT
APPROVAL PROCESS OF OF ANALYZING
THE VARIOUS SOLUTIONS TO REPLACE
THE SYSTEM SO -- I THINK WE'RE
SEEING SOME DELAYS BECAUSE WE
ANTICIPATED FISCALE WOULD BE
ABLE TO TAKE OVER THE
FUNCTIONALITY.
ARE WE REPLACING OR WE UPDATING.
WE ARE UPGRADING THE PLATFORM
ORIGINALLY WE ACTUALLY WERE --
ANTICIPATING REPLACING IT AND
AFTER FORM WOULD GET US TO THE
SAME OBJECTIVE BUT IN A MORE
COST EFFECTIVE AND TIMELY WAY.
IN THE ANALYSIS IF I MAY UM WAS
CHAIRED THE ANALYSIS. FOR THE
THE THE ITEM JUST BEFORE TO DTS
SEE FAILED TO COLLECT AN
ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED NINETY
FOUR MILLION CLEANUP COSTS.
FROM POLLUTERS SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN PHIL TO SEND OUT
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
MILLION AND BILLS.
AND FOR THE FIFTY TWO MILLION IN
ASSESSMENTS.
DTS HE DID MAIL BUT NEVER
COLLECTED.
WHAT'S GOING TO CHANGE.
WELL THE LEGISLATURE -- PROVIDED
US WITH RESOURCES TO DO A
THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF OUR COST
RECOVERY -- PROCESS SEES IN WE
IMPLEMENTED A COST RECOVERY WORK
PLAN -- TO REENGINEER OUR
BUSINESS PROCESS SEES --
ADDITIONALLY LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE GRANTED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO ASSIST WITH AND THE
MOST IN TRANSGENIC INTRANSIGENT --
COST RECOVERY CASES -- WE'VE
ACTUALLY REDUCE STAR AMOUNT OF
UNREIMBURSED COSTS FROM
HISTORICAL LEVEL OF SEVEN POINT
SIX MILLION TO TWO MILLION
ANNUALLY -- AND WE'VE ALSO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF ORIGINAL
SITES OUT OF THE AUDIT THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO WHICH WAS
THE STATE AUDITOR AUDIT.
WE'VE REDUCED -- THE NUMBER OF
SITES -- FROM AND ONE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE TO A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN AND
THAT'S FROM THAT TWENTY FIVE
YEAR BACKLOG PERIOD THAT ENDED
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST -- TWENTY
TWELVE AND IT'S THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE LA -- THAT
WE UPGRADE.
THIS OUTDATED SOFTWARE PROGRAM.
YES WE HAD ART IT EXPELLED LOOK
AT THIS PROPOSAL AND THAT IS OUR
RECOMMENDATION.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOUR PHONE.
JUST A QUICK QUESTION SINCE YOU
YOU BROUGHT UP THIS GALLON THE
THE IN OPERABILITY OF THE TWO SO
IS FISCALE.
STILL WORKING ON SOMETHING TO
ADDRESS THIS OR ARE YOU JUST
CREEK -- HIS NOW THE PATH THAT
YOU'RE GOING FORWARD IS TO
CREATE A PROGRAM INDEPENDENT OF
FISCAL TO DO THIS.
THE ORIGINAL INTENT WAS ON THE
ORIGINAL FOUGHT AND I DON'T WANT
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THIS GAL
BUT AND THE ORIGINAL THOUGHT WAS
THAT THE FUNCTIONALITY IN THE
SYSTEM WOULD BE ABLE -- TO
MANAGE THIS PARTICULAR BUSINESS
PROCESS.
I'M AND AFTER SOME FURTHER
ANALYSIS IT WAS DETERMINED THAT
THE SYSTEM ACTUALLY ISN'T GOING
TO BE CONFIGURED TO COVER THIS
BUSINESS PROCESS AND SO WE BEGAN --
PURSUING OUR OWN UPGRADE -- OF
THE OF THE SYSTEM SO I IMAGINE
AND I'M NOT A TECHNICAL PERSON
AND  DO HAVE MY CHAU HERE BUT
THERE WILL BE SOME -- CERTAINLY
SOME -- INTERFACE BETWEEN
FISCALE AND THE SYSTEM IT'S JUST
THAT THIS PARTICULAR BUSINESS
PROCESS IS GOING TO OCCUR
OUTSIDE OF THE FISCAL SYSTEM.
SO OKAY SO THE SO I'M JUST I'M
JUST MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
DUPLICATING EFFORT WERE FISCAL
STILL TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
THAT YOU GUYS ARE STILL CHAO
ITSELF WHERE WE WE HAVE BEEN --
WE'VE HAD YEARS OF OF MEETINGS
WITH THE SCALE IN IN TALKING
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE --
TO TRY AND SEE IF WE COULD --
INCLUDED WITHIN THE
FUNCTIONALITY -- IN THOSE IS ANY
FISCAL SAY THAT IT CAN'T BE DONE.
RIGHT THEY THEY INDICATED THAT
IT WOULD BE -- IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE STATE FOR US TO
PURSUE UPGRADING OUR SYSTEM
[inaudible]
THAK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
IS THERE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING NONE WE ARE -- ASKED TO
APPROVE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
THAT IS -- DETAILED IN THE AIR
GENDER IS THERE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
HELLO THANK YOU HI FONG.
BY GARCIA.
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
THANK YOU THAT A IS OUR LAST
ITEM ARE THERE ANY ADD ONS THAT
EVERYONE GET TO VOTE ON EVERY
ITEM OR VOTE CHANGE.
IN THIS UNION. ONE FOR TIME.
SO I JUST YOU CAN WRITE
[inaudible]
THAT IS.
SO -- FOR ISSUE.
FORTY THREE ON VOTE ONLY I'D
LIKE TO CHANGE MY WHAT FROM I
TEND NOT VOTING [inaudible]
THINKING [inaudible]
OKAY.
RICHARD THANK YOU